Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier,
and welcome to Space Pirate Trainer.
Now, I was just playing this game
and it- it went a little wrong.
uh..
EUGH!
AHH!
OH!
......
fuck
There's a ceiling there..
I need to be more careful about my
physical space because reality is not
as cool as virtual reality.
But either way, welcome to this game.
It is
Freakin' amazing!
So
Oh! That's SO cool!
OOAAH! Look at that!!
[high pitched]  OOOH THAT'S AMAZING!
OH! That's so cool!
Alright.
So, here's the deal.
This game is freakin' awesome
I just got done playing Brook Haven Experiment
and that game was amazing.
I wanna play that again on my own just
cause it's so fun.
This one might be just as fun because
it's the same concept;
But you're training to be a SPACE PIRATE!
oooooooooh look at that!
Duel death lasers.
EEEAAAHHH suck laser!
Suck laser!
OOOH IT'S SOO COOOOL!
OOH IT'S SOO COOL!
And the music's not bad either.
And so long as I'm not jumping around like a
goddamn fool-
trying to-
DEEUEGHHGH
GET MELTED!
ugh, so long as I'm not jumping around
like a fool and trying to be an idiot
I should
be ok and be capable
of
every-
Ooo where'd you-
where'd you go?
ahhhh!
OH!
WOAH!
WOAH
woah
Dodged you, bitch!
Dodged you!
WOAH!
Hey!
You wanna fight?
You wanna fight bruh?
Aint gonna happen.
See the guns got alot of different
uh
things that it could do.
So I could mix 'em up between the two.
But I like the double lasers.
It's just fancy and free.
Where do you think you're going?
[weird mark voice] Where do you think you're goin'?
I'm gonna get tangled-
[high pitched] AHHHH!
woah
Dodged ya!
I'm like in the matrix!
I'm like the Neo~
At least it's giving me a good boundary box of where I can go-
woah!
ooooooooooo kay!
Don't cross the STREAMS
woahhh hey!
WOAH HEY WOAH WOAH WOAH WOAH!
See I could use a shield
you do have a shield as well like this
so this can block bullets
but I'm gonna dodge them because I'm frickin' awesome!
and I really want to get in my workout today, apparently...
nope
you can also, like, if they start firing
you can, like, just tap em
WOAH- whe-
woah!
ohhh
OH oh
WOAHHHHHH [x1]
WOAHHHHHH [x2]
WOAHHHHHH [x3]
[high speed] WOAHHHHHH [2x]
oh woah woah
AHH- what's that?
what's that in my face?
get my shield outta there
I don't need a shield- OKAY we're gonna go
full on [zapping noises start]
WOAH pfff
Wooooo! Goodbye!
oh it's SO go-  it's soooo cool guys
it's SOOOO cool!!
Ah fuck, laser! WOAH
wha- OHH
habahh ha
habah habah
woah woah
woah woah woah- [girlish scream] AHH
Oh goddammit they got me!
Oh they got me! I'm hit!
Ohhh it's okay!
yes!
yes!!
YEAAHH SLAY!
okay
ah
WOAHh god this might be a problem!
Might be a problem...
Might be a problem..
wooo
Might be a problem!
It's okay.
Not a problem.
WOAH WOAH FUCK YOU!
WOAH!!!
WOAHHH
OH YES!
oh, sorry.
I put on earbuds so that I wouldn't have to-
[Lasers]
scream all the time.
I'm just
a little excited about the-
[activate girl mark] AHHH WOah
ohhh hohohohoooohh
How 'bout 'cha fuck off?
woahhhh
Ah! GODDAMMIT who's hitting me?
AHHH WHAT?
This seems like death!
Awww I wasn't paying attention!
ughhhhhh
ughhh
'MAK'
Awww, I almost beat my other high score
Of course I went with shield before last time, but
I think-
AHHHHH I JUST PULLED ON MY HEAD!
I think double gun is the way to go.
because
mee
likeyyy
dodging!
Bam bam!
ohhh
So satisfying!
Oh it's so satisfying!
You can technically aim through these
but then you can only look down one at a time
so you're better off just finding the center point
and then shooting with reckless abandon.
[softly] You wanna come for me?
[crickets chirping]
So I'm gonna have...
My old favorite was...
these, cause they're basically just, just -uh- super lasers
so long as you got your aim right
woah!
wo- Woah!
woahh woah
WOAH!
[derpy scream]
WO!
Ah, goddammit! I don't have my aim right!
woah woah woah!
AHHHH
stop it!
Ahhhh god dammit- okay
so I gotta find the right weapon, because otherwise I'm just gonna be..
I'm gonna be- fubber nucked
[Mark doing the dance of his people]
(oh why do I love you mark?) (Other person:" The dance is so charming, Aint it?, i wish i had those amazing moves!")
[Mark continues to do the dance of his people. He has called them.]
[They will arrive soon. Prepare yourself.]
Ah, okay.
[exhales]
Okay! This is gonna be the one, this is the one!
This is the one, I ain't fooling around this time!
I'm all matrix-y
I'm ready to go!
I'm in the best shape of my life!
woah
upf!
What- that didn't even give me slow-mo!
What the hell is that talking about?!
Okay
I'm doin' okay
I'm doin' good
Doing good
like we knew we would.
Doing good!!
Bring it on!
Bring it on, bring it on!
WOAHHH woah
Woah what are ya doin'?
Woah woah.
AHHHH
WOAH jeezums!
ayyoohhh!
Woah nelly!
Wow nelly!
aAAH
I'm on the ground!!
I shouldn't be on the ground!!!
[high pitched scream] aAAAH
WAAH
wahoohooho
woohoohoohoo
woo!
wooooo!!
hooooooo-ly crap
okay.
[heavy breathing]
this is really giving ma-
I''m really giving it my all, guys
I'm giving aaaaaaall on the ground!
Leaving it aaaaall on the table!
woooh
oouPP
pffFUCK
RAAAAA
Can I shoot them??
Their lasers out of midair?
I think that's what I did!
Okay.
We're going to... lasers again
baaaah
Ballin' lazers!
There's fuucking lasers everywhere!
If it has the added bonus
of preventing them
from hitting me
cause it delays them
and I'm out of breath
because GAWDDAMMIT
I haven't moved this much since
MAHHH
AHH
I don't know!
I can't even come up some thing clever!
AHH!!
Give me batteries back!
AHHHHH!!!
I need lasers!
Aw shit!
WAHH!!!
Who doing that?
Who do that?
I don't want that.
Whop! Who's doing it?
Who? Where?
Goddammit! Someone behind my back?
What the fuck!
Whoaaa!
Fuck you!
Fuck you! (2x)
Fuck you! (3x)
Fuck you! (4x)
Fuck you! (5x)
Fuck you! (6x)
Fuck you! (7x)
Okay.
Wha- Who? Goddammit!
[Frustrated yelling]
I'm giving it all my all, guys!
I can beat...
my other high score!
I can beat!
I don't need a shield!
I just gotta focus one at a time and not lose 'em.
There's a radar there that can show me where they are-
I am so sweaty right now, but it's all for the better!
It's all for good,
It's all for greatness.
Which is what I have...
Greatness is all that I know!
I am the best!
And I will only be the beEEEST
if you guys BELIEVE in MEEE~
Okay, so I can alternate one gun then the other
if I want to let one recharge...
Bam! Okay, cleared them out good.
I'm getting better with these lasers!
My score is way higher than it was last time!
Where're YOU going?
NOPE! I said NOPE!
I don't even have to dodge like a maniac.
WHOA!
I do- I do have to dodge.
Like a maniac.
Yeah, I can clear their bullets outta the way.
He's still alive down there!
There we go.
Okay.
Woo!
WOOOOO!
WOOOOOO!
Nooo you do not!
Okay, just like that.
My score already has beaten the high score!
I'M ALREADY THE KING!-
Ohhh god, here they come!
Oooh that's a lot of you!
There's a lot of you, but I'm ready!
Nonono, no no no no-
uwAAAAOOOH!
uwaaAAAAEEEY!
[Rapid-fire 'Whoa'-ing]
Okay.
The implementation of like, physically dodging is SO AMAZING!
Like, I mean, I'm all for hyperbole most of the time,
but, to be honest, this is literally like,
this changes everything!
I'm physically here, and it's
uUUUTILIZING!...
that aspect of what I do!
Like, it's utilizing the physicality of it!
I'm literally here!
I'm moving!
It's BONKERS!
Got them, got them, YES!
Okay, I'm getting better hand-eye coordination
so that I can actually move this appropriately
where I need to GOOO!~
Where I need to GOOO!~
The glowy ones are the ones that are gonna shoot on you next.
You gotta watch for those bastards!
Whoah!
Whoawhoah, whoawhoa
That's scary! That's scary! That's super scary!
Woh!
Whoahahhaa fuck!
Okay, I don't know where they are-
WHOAH! Whoa!
Whoaahah!
Woh!
Woh- Ah, shit!
Whoah god!
Whoh!
Haa!
Haa-
AHHH!
NO you don't!
OHH I'm not ready for that!
That was actually leGITIMATELY SCARY!
WHOOOH!
WHOOOOOH!
YEEES!
[through gritted teeth] YEEEES!
MMMMM MOTHER!
MOTHER HUMPER!
Okay.
No nono.
Whoa- UWAH FUCK!
AWW!
Oh, man!
'MRK' with the high score!
At least for here!
Oh, man. Doing that without a shield is so much harder
but it is so much more fun!
Let me just put my...
double shields on the ground here...
take this off....
And thank you everybody so much for watching.
This is SO fun!
I cannot describe...
how COOL
but how physically demanding...
But that's good! I am dripping with sweat,
but I haven't had that much fun in so long!
It's so cool!
So, thank you everybody so much for watching,
there's so many more cool virtual reality stuff coming in the future.
I really hope you guys enjoy watching this,
thanks again for taking the time.
And as always,
I will see YOU
in the next video!
Buh-bye!
[Outro music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]